ald
[Silence]
We are continuing this
evening in our journey and our reading
commentary on the
book
Provisions to be taken for the day of
the great
appointment meaning the day of
resurrection and these Provisions are
taken from the traditions and ways of
the best of the Servants of Allah the
prophet Muhammad s
alai this book of course
authored by the late and esteemed
scholar of
Islam as we've mentioned before this
book is an extreme extremely crucial
book in the Islamic
Library the way it was originally
written was more a
journal than it is an a book that is
written in a particular
order and that is
that he wrote this book from memory and
this book that I have here was about
200 or so Pages this is not the original
book this is just a u an Abridged
version that kind of takes the Crux of
each of the issues and and puts it
all into this very small Abridged
version the original version
is roughly roughly a close to
2,000
or 2500 pages and it is traditionally
printed in five
volumes was written from memory
because he went to
make and on his journey to Hajj which
would take
months back then he decided to write
this book as they were
traveling so he would write this book
and any of his spare or free time during
his travel to Hajj and from
Hajj and so he didn't have any
references
to site the different things that he
mentioned he mentioned them from
memory which is an amazing feat that an
individual can write such a dense and
such
a such a
profound book such as Z that really
is a reference book in its original form
and it has been ever since published
this book
and this book of course was something
that he wrote from memory but he quoted
from over 200 different sources
verbatim in most cases and and he
did this from
memory and this shows the the
enormous amount of Prestige and the
enormous amount of knowledge
that was endowed with by
Allah we were
discussing in this
book The the
original part of this chapter which
was
the way that the prophet
s would traditionally make prayer at
night and how
many and so forth that he would pray s.
wasam and this is an important point and
that is that there are things which
are particular to the prophet Muhammad
Sall there are things which are
obligatory upon Him
particularly there are things which are
must or preferable for him
particularly etc etc there are things
that are Haram for him
particularly aside from the rest of the
umah
these are the particulars of prophethood
in general or the particulars of the
Prophet
muhammad. wasam alone these have all
been
documented by the scholars of Islam
some have even written independent books
on this topic but one of those things
is prayer at night prayer at night in
the correct
opinion has always been an obligation
upon the prophet Muhammad s. wasam and
something which is highly recommended
for the rest of his Nation his umah s.
wasam and so it is something which is an
obligation upon him and this is one of
the first things that he was obligated
with in Islam in
Allah opens the verses
of by commanding the prophet
s. to pray at night and this is an
obligatory and a binding command by
Allah subhanahu waala to his prophet
sallai wasallam
as for the rest of his Nation it is
something which is highly recommended so
much so that the prophet sallam referred
to it
as he said the
dignity the
Integrity the honor of the believer is
found in prayer at night
Allah he speaks about what the prophet
Sall
wasam would say when he would wake up
at night and some Scholars mention this
is something that he would say every
time he would awaken
see sleep is a type of death okay it is
a minor death because of this Allah
subhanahu waala negates that he sleeps
subh he says
no so he affirms for himself that he is
the ever living so he affirms for
himself the epitome of life and he
negates for himself the most minor of
death he says he is not overtaken by
Slumber or sleep exhaustion or sleep he
is not overtaken by fatigue or sleep
sin and so this is something which is
particular to Allah subhanahu wa taala
that he subhanahu waala does not sleep
and he is not overtaken by the
prerequisites of sleep which are a
sin which is fatigue
exhaustion the beginning stages of
sleep these are things that Allah
subhanahu waala does not suffer with
as for the human being our life
is something that is particular it is
befitting to us it is a life that is
our
our sense of liveliness it is deficient
as everything is with the human being
Allah subhanahu Waal
says the human being is not perfect at
anything and this is part of the
Perfection of the human being is that
the human being is imperfect so the the
human being is perfectly imperfect if
you will and that is a concept that is
very important for us to understand and
so Allah subhanahu waala has mentioned
for himself the epitome of life this is
why his name one of his names Al right
and the human being we are our lives our
liveliness our life it is deficient in
its Essence it's deficient in its
existence it's deficient in its end
right meaning that our life comes only
after death so we were first Dead
meaning that we were first inanimate we
were first not alive and we were
brought into
life Allah says you were all deceased
you were all dead and he brought you to
life our life itself is succumbs to
weakness our life itself succumbs to
things that are contradicting to life
such as illness disease fatigue and
ultimately sleep right and
so we have to look at death and sleep
as being very similar sleep is the
Lesser death it is a type of death it is
the Lesser death or the a minor death
right that we experience as human beings
and because of this reason Allah
subhanahu wa taala
refers to death in the Quran and he
refers to sleep in the Quran with the
same terms so he says Allah
so in the Quran refers to either death
or it refers to sleep depending on the
context right so when Allah subhah says
to he says I am going to give you wa
which is it could be interpreted as
sleep or could be interpreted as death
as we
know has not died therefore it is sleep
Scholars of Islam tell us that Allah
subhanahu waala retrieved Isa from
his pursuers in his
sleep and so if we look at sleep in this
way then we need to look at how the
prophet s. wasam would treat sleep how
would he treat it he would make W before
he goes to sleep s. wasam he would
say certain AAR as he is before he goes
to
sleep and he gives the companion
certain ways to go to sleep you go to
sleep on your right side recite this
verses recite this Dua right and then
he and this these Dua these verses or
these supplications that we say just
before our sleep they are
supplications which speak a lot about
life and death oh Allah if you take my
soul in my sleep then forgive it if you
if you allow me to live another day
then protect my soul with that which you
protect the most righteous of your
servants Etc these are the meanings that
supplications of the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam pre sleep revolved
around right and likewise when he would
awaken when he would wake up from this
sleep he has well treated waking up from
this sleep as if he had been resurrected
after his death so one of the things
that he would say when he would wake up
alhamdulillah
all praise is due to Allah the one who
has brought me to life after he had
given me death after he had taken me in
death subhanahu waala this is this is
the way that we are to treat sleep and
the way that we are to treat
life he says
[Silence]
one of the one of the supplications
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would make when he would wake
up at night to pray is he would say that
which translates to none is rightfully
worshiped but you all glory is to you
you oh Allah I seek forgiveness from you
on behalf of my sins and I seek your
Mercy oh Allah increase me in
knowledge and do not turn my heart
away after you have guided me and Grant
me and give to me from you a special
Mercy indeed you are the wab the one who
gives and the Gift Giver the one who is
abundant in his gifts subhanahu
waala then
says and when he would wake up from
his sleep or stir awake he would say all
praise is due to Allah the one who has
given me life after he has taken me with
death and to him is our return
right and then he would brush his teeth
s. brush his teeth it doesn't mean that
he would brush his teeth with Colgate it
does mean that he would use what is
commonly known as AEK and AEK is what
this type of stick it's taken from the
it's taken from the root of the arak
tree right which is customarily found
in
in the that demograph of where the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
from and he would use this seac and I'm
sure most of those who are listening
right now are familiar with it he would
use it to clean his teeth and he
would do this
constantly now does this mean that in
order for us to follow the Sunnah we
have to use that particular tree or that
particular root and this is a thing
you know because you can buy a box and
it's seek and you go out and you buy it
and you use that particular seac and so
on and so forth we say if you use it
that is fine
and that is acceptable excuse
me however it is not necessary to have
fulfilled the sunna to fulfill the
Sunnah one must brush his teeth with
whatever it is that will clean his or
her teeth this is something that is part
of the what does that mean the the the
prophet Sall wasam says 10 aspects are
part of the pre disposition or the
proper nature of the human
being of hygiene right and he
mentions different things trimming
the fingernails trimming the mustache
growing the beard and one of the things
that he mentions is cleaning the teeth
that a person brush his teeth right and
he said
s
in oh in
he said that cleaning your teeth is
something that not only purifies your
mouth and purifies your teeth but as
well it is something that pleases the
Lord pleas pleases Allah subhanahu wa
taala and
consequently cleaning the teeth is
something the prophet sallallah alaihi
wasallam would do whenever he would
enter the house from
outside was asked what is the first
thing he would do whenever he would walk
into the home from outside she said he
would brush his teeth s. wasam he
would clean his teeth right he would
clean his teeth before every prayer he
would clean his teeth every time he
would make W he would clean his teeth
every time he would wake up right from
sleeping and the last action of the
Prophet s. wasam as he departed this
Earth on his deathbed was that he
brushed his teeth s. wasam this is the
last act that he
did and it's kind of sad
that this is something that the Muslims
have started to become complacent
with this is this is one of the things
that makes our time so ironic and so
unfortunate and so absurd the time that
we live in
today because we see that the Muslims
who were the leaders of the of the world
in hygiene in Justice in
scholarship in scientific discovery in
political Affairs
right are now exactly the opposite we're
behind everybody else right and
so we do
things sometimes that are part of the
Sunnah we do not do them but when we
come to America or we see people around
us doing them we do them for that reason
because this is something that we are
taught is the correct thing to do so you
will meet some people Muslims that
for instance have very very
their teeth is are are very
unhygienic their mouth is very
unhygienic their breath is is very
terrible occasionally or a lot of times
right the prophet
sallallah
in was narrated to had brushed his teeth
and he would also brush his tongue
s. and ab it was narrated that he would
brush his tongue so deeply into his
mouth that he would gag and he would say
h right when you go back really far and
brushing your tongue right that's where
bad breath really
lives okay bad breath really lives on
the back of the tongue where the tongue
meets the throat and so he would Sall
alai wasallam brush his tongue far back
all the way till his
gag this narration is
in right and he would brush his teeth so
often that when he would smile his teeth
would also often resemble to the
onlooker his teeth would often resemble
to the onlooker A String of Pearls right
because they would be so shiny and
well taken care of and the only time
the prophet s. wasam had any problems
with his teeth or damage to his teeth
was in war in the Battle
of where one of his teeth was
broken when he was
attacked other than this his teeth were
perfectly well taken care of his breath
was always refreshing and it's
interesting because a very famous author
once
said that people will for get what you
say and people will forget eventually
what you do but people will never forget
how you make them
feel people will never forget how you
make them feel what does that mean all
right we are essentially the human
nature is that we are emotional before
we are
logical and so people will reject the
truth based on emotion and they will
accept falsehood based on
emotion they will accept and justify
falsehood because it makes them feel
good and they will reject and falsify
the truth because it makes them feel bad
and for this reason the prophets and
Messengers and especially the prophet
Muhammad s. wasam was very clean very
hygienic his breath did not have any
foul stench and even even his sweat
was had a positively pleasant smell
to it liken to that of musk or
perfume person may say well why is this
important for a messenger yes it is
important for a messenger or anybody who
is delivering the truth that they be
similar they be hygienic that they be
well kept that they be well groomed that
they have a good smelling breath
and if they don't have good smelling
breath or a good smell at least they
don't have a bad smell or a foul odor
right if they are not positively kind
they are not Negative they are not
people that drive people away
and so Allah subhah waala tells us that
even the companions as great and as
saintly as they were had
they been treated by the prophet
sallallah alai was with harshness and
hard-heartedness he would have driven
with this harshness many of them
away and
so you may speak to to a person who is
very
knowledgeable very well groomed very
well-kept and they are very well spoken
and they are speaking the truth but they
have bad breath and so when you're
speaking to them you will find yourself
disagreeing with them simply because of
how offensive you find their breath to
be or their or their smell to be this is
this is is very true this is something
that happens it's one of the things that
human beings have about them that
psychologically we Express
disgust with rejection so if we are
disgusted by something we automatically
resent it we dislike it even if it's
likable in itself right and so it's it's
very important for a Muslim to always
keep himself well groomed keep herself
well groomed a woman however is never
to wear perfume outside of her home
ever this is something that is
considered by many scholars of Islam to
be a major sin and actually a and a type
of and this is something also that we
see a woman will spray herself with
perfume or you use some kind of perfume
and go out into public this is something
that is not only Haram but it is a major
sin and in one
narration
in it's mentioned
that narrated to a woman that he smelled
perfume from
who was going to the Masjid she had the
best of intentions and he said to her I
heard the prophet s. wasam that a woman
say that a woman's Salah would not be
accepted if she goes out into public
wearing perfume and that perfume is
smelled by a man who is not related to
her or not legal for her to be intimate
with and her Salah will not be
accepted until she goes home home and
bathes the bathe the bathing of janab
which is sexual impurity and this is to
articulate the seriousness of this issue
because this is something
that is will draw attention to her and
draw attention to her in a very sexual
Manner and I wish that we would
understand these things
people will say well if she doesn't wear
perfume she'll smell bad that's not true
at all actually if a person keeps
himself clean hygienically clean they
won't smell bad at all because the
Muslim does not
consume we do not eat things which are
filthy we do not eat filthy animals we
do not eat filthy things right and
second of all the Muslim does not have
any filth on him he is constantly
praying and constantly washing himself
all over the most important parts of
his body and constantly bathing and
so the Muslim is pure inside and out
internally the Muslim is pure and
externally the M Muslim is pure and so a
person will not have a foul odor if they
follow the guidelines of Islamic
hygiene and so for a person to
constantly brush his teeth to keep his
breath smelling good or at least not
smelling bad this is something that is
very important imagine yourself at a
wonderful
restaurant imagine
yourself eating the best of food that
you could imagine most perfectly
presented and most perfectly
prepared but the waiter or waitress that
brings you your food has bad breath or
smells or is unkempt this would make us
dislike the food or at least not it
as much and would disgust us this is why
hygiene is so
important in Islam and so those
first Impressions a person may be
speaking to you and as we said well
dressed well spoken well educated what
they're saying is true and you cannot
remember what the person said but all
you can remember is that this person had
terrible breath or had a terrible smell
or was unclean or was unhygienic that
this person has activated a very
strong emot Motion in us that overrides
our mind and that is disgust so it's
important that we keep this in mind the
prophet sallallah alai wasallam would
constantly brush his teeth so much that
in one narration he said
s. jel continued to command me to brush
my teeth till I was afraid I would brush
them into Decay I would brush brush
them into brittleness into Oblivion that
he would brush his teeth so much that he
would start breaking his teeth this is
obviously to drive home and
exaggerate the importance of brushing
one's teeth brushing brushing one's
mouth and as we mentioned brushing one's
tongue that the prophet sallallah alai
wasam used to do
often and so the first thing he would do
when he would wait wake up s. wasam is
he would brush his teeth now why do we
experience bad
breath
well it's important for us to
understand
the way
that dental hygiene has developed in
America especially this is where we live
especially in the last century the last
100 years
about a hundred years in
America a little
less this is
when toothpaste was really
developed and sold in America and the
idea of brushing your teeth really came
to America it was very weird very un un
very taboo almost for a person to
constantly brush his or her
teeth and so when toothpaste was
developed it was very slow selling and
this is a true story tooth toothpaste
would not be sold very much people it
just didn't catch on in America and so
they brought in some advertisement
experts to kind of think about how they
could get people to start to by their
product and so what they did is in
America they created a
culture
of toothbrushing and dental hygiene in
order to sell their
product and so the origins of brushing
teeth in America is not because of
dental hygiene or because of
sophistication it was driven by money it
was the
toothpaste companies and and Pioneers
at the time who started to really
campaign for brushing teeth and so when
brushing the teeth first came out and
they were advertised on billboards it
didn't catch on and they realized that
one of the reasons it did not catch on
is there was no discernable
reward for brushing your
teeth because the toothpaste that they
used had no particular taste to it right
it had no taste and actually it didn't
foam either pay attention this is this
is you know if you want to see the
origins of this this is where it comes
from toothpaste when you put it in your
mouth and you rub it around it's it's
almost soap it starts to turn into
a foam and it has Suds to it and Bubbles
right and also it's Tangy and Zippy and
it has a mint taste that almost kind of
makes your mouth sensitive and burn
this was not how original toothpaste was
original toothpaste was dull you put it
on and it was mainly you know U
baking soda or whatever they used at the
time and it would not foam up and it
didn't have any particular taste to it
and your reward is that your teeth would
be white
allegedly well they found found that
that was not a discernable enough reward
for people to brush their teeth so what
did they
do they
added they added things to it to make
it foam
up when it interacts with water when it
is brushed around and they put mint into
it to give your mouth that aftertaste
that makes you feel better that you have
actually brushed your teeth so they'd
put things cinnamon or mint in it
and so what would happen is they
advertise that that as part of your
morning routine as part of your evening
routine you're going to brush your teeth
right and you're going to
feel the suds build up in your mouth and
you're going to feel and taste the
mintiness and it's going to make your
mouth sensitive right almost you
ate Peppers or something and that slight
tanginess or that slight zippin in your
mouth that was the reward that was
discernable enough for people to develop
habits
psychologically right this is how habits
are actually formed they are formed with
the
suggestion the action and then the
reward this is called the reward Loop in
Psychology and this is what cause people
to catch on to brushing the teeth but
then there was another
problem manufacturers of toothpaste
were not moving enough
product right so we got to move more
product how can we get people to use
more
toothpaste so they started to make
bigger
toothbrushes right the toothbrush would
originally be a certain size they made
it WI
and they made it longer and they
advertise all kinds of magical features
for this
toothbrush to justify $15 that you're
going to pay for it because it reaches
here and reaches there and does this and
does that and massages your gums and all
this stuff and they figured out that in
Trials Americans will always put the
same length of toothpaste on the
toothbrush
whatever those bristles are they will
always fill that up all right so they
made the tooth they made the toothbrush
longer they made it wider another thing
they did was they made the opening to
the tooth toothpaste tube they made it
bigger so you're going to put the same
length on there but you're putting more
substance down right more toothpaste
down on it caused people to use
toothpaste more and so it becomes a
thing now where if you don't have
toothpaste you haven't brushed your
teeth if you don't use this toothbrush
you haven't brushed your teeth you have
to do it in the morning you have to do
it in the evening and so we came and we
learned these
things we didn't take the advice and the
action of the Prophet Sall
alai that if you brush your teeth and
remove the dirt and remove the debris
and remove the leftover food if you
brush your teeth even if there's no
toothpaste with anything that is a brush
if you brush your teeth at every prayer
you brush your teeth when you wake up
you brush your teeth whenever you go
into your home you brush your teeth
at every wo right your teeth will be
very white they will be very clean and
your breath will subsequently be very
pleasant as well so we did not take this
advice and we took the advice of brush
your teeth in the morning and brush your
teeth in the evening before you go to
bed after you wake up brush your teeth
with Colgate use this fancy toothbrush
use this super fancy toothpaste that
does 10in one things it whitens and
it freshens and it this and it that and
all these things and all it is is just
FL flavor in the mouth there's nothing
proven that these things actually
do right and so we take this and we only
brush our teeth in the morning and in
the evening and so what happens all
throughout the duration of the day we're
eating some people are smoking some
people are drinking very sugary
things and what happens the breath
becomes terrible the teeth start to
decay in spite of brushing our teeth
with the best and the baddest and so now
they're coming out with all these
different kinds of gadgets and we have
to understand that this is not the way
that the prophets and Messengers taught
us to
maintain our me Dental hygiene
our dental hygiene we brush our teeth
frequently throughout the day and even
if a person doesn't use the seek itself
if they just use a regular toothbrush
just a regular dollar toothbrush and
they wash it off every time they use it
and they use it just before prayer rinse
their mouth or use it just before W
right this will you will have
achieved the Sunnah and you will have
had a very hygienic mouth and a pleasant
breath and you will have pleased Allah
subhanahu waala by following the Sunnah
of the prophets and Messengers
so when the prophet sallam would wake up
from his sleep he would first say
alhamdulillah he would say all praise is
due to Allah the one who has given us
life after he has taken us with death
and to him is our return and then he
would brush his teeth
and then sometimes he would recite
the last 10 verses the closing 10 verses
of which would start with the
statement of
Allah in which Allah subhanahu wa
taala says in the closing verses that
which translates to indeed in the
creation of the heavens and the Earth
and the change of day and night and
the rotation of day and night there are
signs for the people of true
intellect these last 10 verses
ofah and then he would
make now it's important for us to
understand these verses meaning the the
last 10 verses ofah
Alan these verses were revealed red to
the prophet
s. during the night time when he was
praying one night he
he
was given these last 10 verses
of and he encourag that anybody
who ever reads these verses that they
always contemplate them deeply as they
are reading
them there
are to be honest an issue that is very
clear not clear to many
people is that in the new secular age
that we are allegedly
in we're be being given a new
religion what what is the new
religion well it's the religion of
allegedly the religion of science right
so science is the
religion and scientists are the
prophets and messengers of this
religion and the God of this religion is
Mother Nature or the universe
right and you will hear people speak
about I asked the universe and I the
universe did for me and I did for the
universe and mother nature and all this
stuff and you know the
evidences are used almost as if it is
a something that has come from Allah
himself and so anytime you read anything
a person is saying something studies
show you know and statistics say and so
on and so forth failing to tell us that
these studies and these statistics can
be Wild misinterpreted they can be
interpreted in many different ways who
are the people that fund these studies
Etc this is another issue but the point
is is
that we
are given all of these articles and all
of these things as if this is our
religion and so you've got Muslims that
are
meditating just Hindus meditate or
Buddhists the same way how do I meditate
till I sit and I think about my
breathing and I only focus on my
breathing etc
etc but the meditation that we have in
Islam is prayer that Salah is
neglected by the same
individual is overlooked the person is
praying they don't know what they're
saying just going through the motions
praying late praying this but every
morning when I wake up I meditate right
and another thing is such as yoga right
this is another issue and another one is
the
Mantra the Mantra what is the Mantra
well allegedly the very successful
people very successful CEOs and so forth
of the of the Modern
Age they they have a Mantra that they
chant to themselves every day when they
wake up right so they say you need to
develop for yourself a
mantra for every day when you wake up
that you need to chant this to
yourself you know to gas yourself up and
to boost yourself up every day for
for the day right and so what is this
Mantra usually something
silly I can be better or I am good
or I am a go-getter whatever kind of
thing people are chanting to
themselves this in
itself maybe have a smidgen of accuracy
to it of truth to
it this is something that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would do but
he would not do it to become rich and he
would not do it to go to the gym and
work out so that he could get his glutes
and his pectorals and everything into
shape so that he could look good on the
beach this is not what this is for the
prophet s. wasam would recite when he
would wake up the last 10 verses
of what are the last 10 verses ofah Al
IM they discuss
that logically a person will come to
realize that this world has not been
created in just that Allah subhanahu wa
taala is not only very powerful but very
forgiving and that we ask Allah to
forgive us because we have to the best
of our
abilities attempted to follow the path
of the prophets and
Messengers we are told to not look at
the life of this world for its parent
aspects that the people of this world
who are upon
disbelief
they're travels and going to and fro
and their enjoyments and their Leisure
Time and their comfort that these are
things that should not fool
us he said this is a very short and
transient
entertainment and enjoyment that will
be replaced with a damnation in the
Hereafter for those who reject Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and his Messengers
that the true
that the true enjoyment the true
fulfillment of our potential is found
with Allah there we will have places
prepared for us to honor those of us who
have struggled in the way of Allah
subhanahu wa taala and he ends these
verses
with oh you who have believed be patient
and be more patient than your enemies be
more patient than those around you and
stay Stead fast and constant in your
good deeds in order that you may attain
success this is what we are to remind
ourselves of every night every morning
when we wake up or every time we wake up
out of sleep we are to recite these
verses meditatively
reflectively to remind ourselves of why
it is we are here where it is we are
going and what it is we are to be doing
and our time time here on this Earth
this is this is the Mantra if you will
of the Muslim when he wakes up and when
we go to bed we recite verses of the
Quran such as
the which reminds us of Allah and his
awesomeness we recite the last verses
ofah Bak which are a plea to Allah that
he forgive us and relieve us and that we
recite Sur mul which discusses the
origins of the human being the nature of
our existence in this world and the
consequences for our choices in the
Hereafter these are the things that we
recite to ourselves when we wake up the
things that we recite to ourselves when
we go to sleep the things that we remind
ourselves of every morning and evening
this is what the Muslim is to do as for
the life of this world is it is a means
to an ends it is not the ends in itself
the life of this world is but a tool to
be used to attain salvation in the
Hereafter and
so says that after the prophet s.
wasallam would wake up he would recite
these verses
from are these verses only to be recited
when a person wakes up from sleeping at
night or are they to be recited anytime
a person
awakes well this is a difference of
opinion amongst the scholars of Islam
but if a person recites these verses
every time they wake up and they arise
from their sleep then that is correct
inshallah and then he
would s. wasam he would purify himself
what does that mean he would purify
himself well he would prepare himself
for prayer if he was in a state of
janaba then he would
make if he was in a state of
minor then he would make w
s and sometimes the prophet s. wasam
would sleep and and he would wake up and
pray
without making
W right so this is now what do you
mean he would wake up and pray without
making
M well this is something which is
particular to the prophet s.
wasam because sleep itself does not
break a person's
wo the act of merely falling asleep does
not break wo
what breaks
wo is the overwhelming
probability that while a person was
sleeping something happened that broke
his wo such as passing gas or what have
you this is
why we make W if we fall into deep sleep
and some Scholars have mentioned the
position a person falls asleep in as
being
in this ruling that if a person sleeps
sitting straight up for instance they do
not have to make some but the correct
opinion is as the prophet
Sall
said he said wasam that the ey is the
leash of the of the
of the person's private part meaning
that once a person falls asleep he may
pass gas or do something that will
nullify his wo so we make wo from deep
sleep we do not make wo from slight
sleep if a person dozes
off but they were awake enough that they
would realize if they had broken their w
they do not have to make up their W the
prophet
sallam would sometimes pray very late
and the best time to
pray is actually at the very middle of
the night right but this is something
that's difficult for most people and
it's better to pray in J even if it is
earlier than to pray later by
oneself and so the companions
they would sit in the mid after and they
would wait for the prophet s to come out
and
lead and what would
happen is the Masid of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam it didn't
have any lights in it right so it's
completely dark in the Masjid
everybody's sitting there they're making
their T they're reciting the Quran and
they are waiting for the prophet
sallallah alai wasallam to emerge and
pray
well in this process some of them might
drift off they've been working all day
they've been you know they're tired and
ANB Malik narrates that some of the
companions would fall asleep to where
their chins were completely supported by
their chests what does that mean they
would be you know completely sleeping
this and that the prophet sallallah
alai wasam would then come out and those
same companions
whoever they were
abak the
companions that would pray with the
prophet
wasallam when he would come out they
would stand for prayer and pray without
remaking their wo so the scholars of
Islam took from this that a slight sleep
to drift off what we say in
this will not break a person's w
[Silence]
was
and so the prophet
s his heart would not sleep while his
body or his eyes would rest so sometimes
he would wake up and pray because he was
aware that he had not broken his woo
throughout the duration of his sleep
we'll continue this topic next week
inshallah
mam